Hi.
I've always been,
I've always been a fan of Jimi Hendrix,
but huge,
huge fan and I'm not just,
I listened to his music all the time,
which I do.
I listen to Jimi Hendrix at least once a week for the longest time when I would
land in any city,
my landing music have landing music that I put on the airport as soon as the
thing.
Boom.
Food child every time.
Fucking years.
Man.
I felt like the lungs time and that's one of the reasons why I decided to call
it a podcast.
Joe Rogan experience as [inaudible] experience [inaudible] I saw
and what it is
his mugshot or uh,
you know,
a series of his mugshot.
Isn't it the same way he was arrested in Toronto,
same photo.
It's just a bunch of images of it is the hardest.
I don't know.
I don't give a fuck.
Don't even today Mike,
we've had some pretty epic podcast for 10 might have the most efficacy.
Cool man.
Yeah,
it was awesome in front of you that day.
Yeah.
I think we've covered a lot.
I had the right mixture of Alpha brain pills,
marijuana,
alcohol and coffee.
It's perfect.
Yeah.
We should add some vitamins.
We didn't take it to the next level.
Here's a few times we were searching for words if we have the vitamins.
Yeah.
Nailed it.
How old was he?
I think
he died when he was 27 what year?
That was 64 I think he died in 63 seeing that this is may one was with 69
Woodstock was 69 oh,
it says may 60 votes.
I thought it was a four so [inaudible] 69
I think it died.
Not that much longer afterwards.
Right.
Shogun on his own farm it like like a champ,
like a champ.
You saw late night.
Podcasts are fucking hit or miss.
Sometimes they work,
sometimes they don't.
You know,
they're,
it's a different vibe and sometimes people are tired and I've worked out,
worked in quotes.
It's not really work,
but I was out in the sun all day and you know,
you get a little,
a little tired,
loopy,
but you might have a weird fucking report.
Dude,
when we do podcasts,
they get very strange.
I know it's not just the podcast,
every conversation.
Yes.
Yeah,
we have gets weird.
Yeah.
We both go to places where we wouldn't necessarily go without each other.
You know,
we might,
I don't know,
but I find myself there way more often with you and super comfortable with it,
you know,
whatever the fuck it is.
Yeah,
man,
we definitely like have an awesome cenergy man.
I just got to get a fucking flotation tank.
I'm thinking about starting a Kickstarter
going down the field lab or go into,
how far are you away from Burbank?
I could do that,
but I've got this garage that she's dying for a flood.
Listen,
any time you have some time off during the day,
you're more than welcome to come here.
And he's cool.
Anytime,
you know,
just come on over,
come on over and use it.
How often do you use it?
All the time.
Every day.
No,
no.
I believe in taking days off.
Um,
I think you can get too addicted to the experience.
So it's a freaky experience.
And I know I'm not,
I don't want to say too addicted,
but I,
I like going in there,
absorbing something,
coming out and then sort of applying that to my life.
And one of the things that I think about psychedelic trips,
about meditation,
about times at a tank,
which I think I find to be different than meditation and different from
psychedelic trips and sort of a combination of the two,
especially when I go in there and eat pot,
which is how I usually do it.
Yeah,
it's pretty intense,
but it's not quite a psychedelic experience,
the regular sentence because of good part of the,
the visual stimuli and the effects that I'm getting.
It's because I'm floating and fucking warm salt water,
you know?
And I feel like I'm flying through space and I have no sensory input going in.
So it's,
it's a weird combination between the two things we should,
meditation and psychedelic experience.
But,
um,
I think in one of the most important parts about any of that stuff,
when your experiment experimenting with consciousness or pushing the boundaries
of thinking ideas,
you've got to be a little applied.
You can't be a cripple in this world.
A mental cripple.
You can't,
you can't,
you know,
just only want to get high or just only one to escape are all there and
meditate.
You know,
why would my instinct when I see like monks is to Meijer their virtue and
admired their,
their discipline,
but also some time to be,
you're not getting any policy.
You're not having sex,
you're not having fun.
You don't listen to good music up there,
you know,
party and you'll never get a little too drunk.
You never really eat a little too much food.
You know,
you don't ever go to see a moat.
May Laugh,
laugh photo too loud.
Come on man.
What are you doing?
You're missing,
you're missing a big thing.
I understand that it's difficult to manage this experience,
but don't tell me you got it right with this minimalist approach because that's
nonsense.
No one's got it.
Yeah,
but maybe me and I'm not you.
Can I play devil's advocate?
Can I play monkeys?
Advocate?
Yeah.
Maybe they look at us the same way cause they plugged in to sometimes a million
times better than music or blocking.
Maybe they've plugged into something bigger.
You're right navy.
Maybe not though.
Maybe the most scared pusses wearing orange robes and they don't get that.
They don't even have cars.
They never gotten a fucking Shelby gt 500 and heard that fucking engine grouth
that four inch pipe
hit that first gear and fucking went sideways
is fun and all these things about them.
It was fun and all these things people live invented great music and awesome
movies and and really comfortable blankets.
They've invented all that shit to make life more awesome.
Give blow blowjobs from other monks may be,
do you really want that?
We don't know.
Do you want a monk?
Blowjobs brown
was enough.
Enough.
Thanks for everything.
See Son party rolls on.
Alright.
When I'm on the road I get jet lag.
I take them the great for hangovers too.
I don't know why.
I don't understand the science behind it.
Don't give it was raving about,
and I guess you gave him some last time he did it.
People are gonna think that this is some sort of a,
uh,
a big,
commercial push.
Like those some reason while we're talking about this other than the fact that
it really works cause I,
the problem is I have a financial interest of this company so people think that
it's all,
of course I'm just,
when you hired Tim Ferriss,
yeah.
Hired
at the author Tim Ferriss to come in,
cause I showed it to him.
I said,
what do you think about the ingredients?
This thing he said he thought it was great.
So it was a perfect combination and then he took it,
he tried it and he liked it and people,
there's some idiots on my message board that were accusing me of hiring him and
like,
even if you're just joking,
it's so annoying.
Like stop.
She says Brandon.
So pretty quickly you uh,
yeah.
You feel pretty quick with that couple of days.
1515.
Oh this is here,
man.
He felt it too.
Tim Ferriss,
he felt it right away.
I don't think I feel it right away.
You know,
like he felt it within an hour or two.
I think it takes me a few hours at the very least have to feel any effect of it.
You know,
I always want to be careful of like,
what is the placebo effect?
I'm not bullshitting myself.
Well,
the main reason why I say I'm not bullshit myself was because of the dreams that
I never had dreams like this before.
There's no way that that is bullshit.
That's because I didn't expect that.
So when it happened,
it was a very tangible result of something new that's been introduced into my
system.
And that's what's been new Alpha brain shit.
And the other thing it does is it I've,
I know I don't sound like a smooth talker right now,
but I'm tired.
I've been working all day.
I do a scene.
It seems to me that my words flow out better.
I'm searching for words less.
I feel cleaner.
I felt like my mind works more crisply.
Yeah.
Do you agree with that?
Do you feel what you feel to,
what's that drug that writers use?
Adderall is like natural Adderall for me.
That's what Dunkin keeps saying.
Dunkin keep saying it's like a mile.
And I'm scared of it.
That sounds awesome.
Out of Adderall scares the shit out of me because I think I would love it.
You know,
some,
some uh,
productivity drug.
That's me,
man.
I fucking out.
And really,
I mean,
uh,
amphetamine salts is what it is.
I have a friend that is David.
A lot of girls hooked on speed and the nightmare stories that he told me
elsewhere in your mid twenties,
they're all,
they were all prescribed it going through grade school.
Yeah.
It's an ADHD drug or add whatever.
But basically like,
so Adderall is just ramp it down.
Yeah.
There's no comics.
Andy kindler takes it.
Does he?
Yeah.
He just started though.
And he said it's changed his life immensely.
Like he went through the,
he,
he's not like a pill head.
Right.
He got prescribed the changes life immensely.
How he said that he had really bad add.
Well,
I don't know if that's something that I do it and I gave us hope,
hope,
trips.
Like I do it.
It makes me have my coke flashbacks.
Yeah.
I mean you can abuse it lasts.
A lot of people do that now.
They'll cut off the pills and snorting,
but like I get,
I have some 30 milligram pills.
I take a quarter of it if like I'm just completely wiped out.
And what does it do for you?
Hey,
I'm here.
Wow.
Yeah.
What does the crash like when it's over?
No.
Do you ever worry about heart attacks or anything?
Oh,
constantly with everything.
The uh,
with the,
um,
no,
like,
you know,
I think about like,
I don't really think about him often,
but like,
yeah,
it's smoking and drinking and,
right.
You know,
getting,
yeah,
closer to 40.
It's like 44,
dude.
Yeah.
Well you exercise pretty,
I do,
but it's like a lot of it is fighting father time.
I mean,
I don't want to make sure that it doesn't slide too far back.
Take vitamins all day and monitoring my health and getting my blood work done
and drinking this crazy green shit they're going to get in and all that shit
that this green drink I drink every morning a drink first thing in the day to
Kevin.
James taught me about it cause he uh,
he lost incredible amount of weight.
He lost like 80 pounds,
started looking great face slimmed up.
And what he did was he started drinking this really healthy plant based smoothie
at the beginning of every day.
So every day starts off of this plant based smoothie.
And the idea is,
first of all,
it's very rare.
There's a lot of roughage.
It's fiber cleans out your system and it's sort of lubes the way up for all the
food that comes behind it.
So the idea is to start off your day with one of these things and it's just sort
of like cleans the track and it makes all of your food digest better,
chew your food much better,
you know,
don't eat shit with a lot of chemicals in it.
And so he just didn't altering his diet that way.
Is potty just for it just fucking changed.
He was basically eating entirely plant based diet for the first time in his
life.
Just changes,
health changed everything changed the way you know,
the way he felt.
He would get up in the morning and feel fucking fantastic like all of his life.
You know,
he's been a big guy and you know,
he's getting older.
His joints were starting to hurt and he said I would get up.
I'd feel like a fucking old man.
He goes,
I started drinking this green drink and drinking it everyday.
No,
no,
no.
It's not prepackaged show you make it.
Yeah.
Well well this is my green shake that I make everything.
This is what I learned this from Kevin James who lost like lost like 80 pounds.
What it is mostly is fresh Kale,
Kale,
cucumber,
celery,
a little bit of um,
ginger and I throw a pair on there as well.
And we do everything about mixing an apple on there.
I
take all this stuff
and I'll bring it over here.
And you know what?
This is awesome for first and foremost,
your poop
poop just slides.
Do is
first thing I chop up,
is there a reason why you use a blender instead of a juicer?
Yeah,
because the a,
the idea is that when you're juicing things,
you're not getting all of the planning and not getting the fiber,
which is great for your body.
What this is is
having to break it all down and chew and chew it and swallow and eat all these
vegetables,
which should be boring as fuck really to eat.
I'm in this state except the payer.
You know,
it's kind of boring,
so what you do is you blend it all up and drink it as a shape.
It's called the Vitamix and it's meant for specifically for this how this works.
[inaudible]
should mix it all up with,
I'm 12
[inaudible]
comes out looking
at the whole case loads.
I'd probably do everything except the ginger.
Ginger is good for any man.
How should that just
got me
super good for you and I've been doing this every day for a few weeks now.
It's one of the nicest things about not being on the road.
When I'm home,
I get to eat super clean and healthy.
So between this and uh,
all the vitamins I take vitamins I take off from the earth,
take fish oil,
testosterone high,
Yo,
you think you need that
Alpha brain course.
Got To keep my brain working,
cockroach me and control me.
Super cheap.
Complex vitamin D three
B,
stress complex.
Niacin record.
Go to bed
e three as well.
Our electric h car enzymes
B complex B in there.
Yes.
Keep your balls off him.
Jack Three d take this right before a workout.
It gets me jacked.
Nitric oxide
aminos amino clear from nutrition.
A company.
I highly recommend.
Very strong products.
That's most of what I think day.
No,
no,
fuck that.
I take pig paths.
Eventually we're going to sell them at the same company selling Alpha brain.
And we're going to do is we're going to package all the highest,
most potent nutrients and put it in a pack so that you don't have to do what I'm
doing.
So you'd have to do this stacking all your stuff and go into stores and buying
things.
We're going to put together a thing.
So just a little comment.
One a day,
a little packet.
Oh,
I get it out.
Take it other,
you're probably not going to take as much as I do.
I take 10 of these dead fish.
I took 10 days,
seven of these,
three of these.
And that's for real though.
I feel fantastic and my mind is super clear and this is a lot of people that
bullshit that thinks this is bullshit.
I think this Alpha brain stuff doesn't work.
I fucking thing it works great because we crazy dreams and I feel fantastic.
I think just like vitamins,
you know,
vitamins work and they help you body and they help keep you tuned to him,
keep you functioning at a high level.
Well,
there's vitamins for your mind to,
and that's what this Alpha brain stuff does.
It's the,
are all vitamins that have been clinically proven or at least anecdotally proven
to,
uh,
help brain function.
I'm going to work to work for you.
Yeah,
that's it folks.
This is my,
um,
my recipe for my Kale,
fake Kaylin salary lost cheers.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Okay,
second blood,
and I saw your scared shit.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Don't fucking bug anybody.
You're creepy.
That's my in mind in the whole day.
Previous a phony war there.
Don't add.
Don't come up to my car again.
I punched the private guides us walking away tonight.
I know you.
I'm your buddy,
but don't come up on your butt.
All fucking scag check again.
We got it right.
I'm watching.
Fuck you.
I'll beat the fuck outta you.
You know I have to say that that Brody Stevens on that video.
I can't him.
You're the same person you are right now sitting here.
You're so calm.
The way you explain it that I'm on Depakote.
Seroquel.
Yeah.